you uh are irish you're from ireland but
you spent a lot of time in the u.s
and uh when i was talking to you
backstage i didn't really detect
an accent no i don't know some people uh
they say it's phony i like to say i have
a musical ear but um
no i moved here in 2002 so i've spent a
lot of time here
right does it ever do you find that your
accent comes and goes like for example
let's say you were having some drinks
uh would your irish accent come would
your irish accent come back
well weirdly i think when i get drunk
now i get even more american
which is a very strange thing i'm like
very l.a
all of a sudden but when i when i was
talking to colin backstage it got very
irish
everyone was like oh she's really irish
again which one
when when you talked to i grew up and
the people that lived next door to my
family the murphys they were
they were real irish guys older guys
from ireland these twin brothers
and they when you listen to a real irish
guy talk you can't understand a word
they're saying no
people think they have this
misconception that it's like the lucky
charms
they sort of talk but real ones are like
i gotta get over here that's it
i don't understand what they're saying
that's how i used to speak before i
moved to america
all right i don't picture you speaking
that way
do you actually speak some gaelic yeah
well
which blows my mind because that's
that's a very difficult language i mean
it's one of the oldest languages in
europe but yeah
i used to be fluent i mean i've
forgotten quite a bit of it now but i
still have a few sayings
do you know like what can you say and
because gaelic i don't even know what
well i could say uh
that's cool it's like dothraki that's
what it sounds like to me
it sounds like game of thrones kind of
it's probably based on it no that's
that's like if you're a little out of
whack and
it's uh you're as bent as a dog's hind
leg that's what that means that's what
that means
i wonder is conan gaelic for anything do
you think or is it just
i mean i think it's probably like strong
ginger man
that is the sweetest thing you could
have said
i looked it up once and it said gaelic
wide head
but you know when you actually see
things written out and gay like it's
impossible my daughter
we wanted her to have an irish name and
we love the name
neve nev and so we said we'll do that
and they
started to they i saw how it's written
out in gaelic
and everyone's like it's like
n-i-m-g-f-h-x-y
it's just they're throwing consonants in
there for no reason
i just have a plethora of vowels i mean
it just confuses everybody they're like
wait what what is
what are those extra words that's right
because your name is spelled very
differently than it's pronounced yeah
yeah here